you guys the fandom for this show is
rabid do you have any idea how your
lives are about to change when the new
season premieres I never expected to
date the model it may look like you have
nothing in common but Jazmin and I are
meant to be together did you guys watch
the show before going on in I just don't
want to go to the party tonight I don't
fit in with Blake and his friends no
stupid you're supposed to be there you
share the most vulnerable parts of
yourself what are we gonna see in
watching you guys's journey because
you're standing here right now like
you're together yeah you know we they
show us you know they tap into a little
bit of my world you know you'll see what
I do with music and they talk about
their her world you know with her and
her gymnastics and everything and her
sister lives out here you know that's
one thing that like a lot of people
don't have is you know where their
spouse or you know their partner there's
family don't live out here but your
sister lives here and it's kind of a
plus well the show's all about drama
though do two things get dramatic
between you guys I would say it kind of
did you know in the beginning it was
kind of like a little bumpy and smooth
for us but I said went down the line it
kind of got nerve-racking and that can
come from anything you're like are you
like I don't even want to get into how
are you together right now you're
speaking very highly of her like I got
into her shows her sisters here so I
mean it's kinda hard not to speak highly
over like either what out whatever you
know the outcome is of her and I you
know I'm it's not like I'm just gonna be
like oh I'm never talking to her again
just because we tried if we both try
something it's not like I tried it and
it failed or something people love it
takes two people you know some people
off this show don't speak to each other
yeah yeah that's a little bit different
I can I can see how that happens but you
know we had a little bit relationship
before the whole proposal and everything
like that you know I it's not like I've
known her for like a few hours or a
couple days you know I know
for a while you know and so so I mean
tell us a little bit about your story
you guys you're from the Ukraine you're
from Finland okay so you guys met how
online how'd you meet we met online she
was out here and that's how we ended up
meeting and then she went back home and
that's when I found out that she was
from Finland what's this whole thing
like been for you to spend all this time
in America a totally different culture I
mean I have visited here before so I
gotta knew where I was like moving to
and like I know him for two years so
like I feel safe around him it was like
[Music]
now this show has rabid fans it also has
people who like to critique and give
their opinions if there are
misconceptions about you guys or
opinions what do you have to say to
those people who might come at you with
a little bit of online hate well what's
the okay well how I take it how we take
it is just like you know negativity we
kind of don't like try to like embrace
that too much but like what to say back
to them it's just like you know they
could they could take it for what it is
you know and well you know one thing
people say a lot is they come at people
and say you're going on the show for
fame if people say that about you guys
what do you have to say I actually was
opposed to not doing the show because
with me in the music industry like I am
an audio engineer I produce and like
yeah my own artist but at the same time
my producing an audio engineering kind
of took off a little bit before I met
her and I like doing that because I'm
behind the scenes like I don't always
have to show my face but I can still get
my credit so at first I was opposed to
doing it but you know the table's kind
of turned a little bit different you
know like things new you know
and our relationship all right any
regrets about any parts of the show
anything you had done differently trying
to live life with no regrets what about
for you any nerves are you guys gonna
watch every episode like I don't like I
don't know I don't think I go with my
sister like I know that like we got to
you like he wants to like how like party
I like like invites people okay I feel
like you wanted to be on the show more
than she did too but like my like you
wanted exactly like she made me realize
I wanted it you know I mean I first I
didn't know if I wanted it that she made
me realize I want it you're holding is
hammering oh do you have an engagement
ring on no we're gonna see what happens
how does doing the show affect your
relationship like what can you guys
tease for us about the ups and downs
that might be ahead now that you put her
on TV like there'll be things that like
we want to do you know I want to show
her around and just like how the process
of filming goes like it doesn't get to
play out how I want it to be so it can
kind of be a bit frustrating and you
kind of see that a little bit on camera
but um you know we all have our personal
things that we'd go through as couples
and I think it's like normal common
things that we go through but you're
staying quiet does that create any
issues in your relationship
no not she prefers it that way but like
if I don't talk then she knows that
she'll have to and so you guys married
if you just had a couple adjectives to
describe what your journey on the show
is gonna be like dramatic passionate
whatever they would be what would the
word static say you got to give me one
say normal
I don't know I wasn't oh I would say
like I'm like drama-free person or like
it's a person so I don't know son fired
[Music]